[Music]
on this wednesday night covet 19 vaccine
vials and dosage difficulties
why precious doses are being wasted
we're short on vaccine
and the vital equipment needed to stop
it
america's new president targets climate
change and it's time to act
his goals for a greener future and how
it aligns with canada
a murderous plot foiled new details
about a potential violent attack against
newfoundland and labrador politicians
plus the pandemic's toll on teenagers it
has been pretty frustrating
the stress struggles and solutions
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with some rare good news about
covid 19 numbers in canada
it appears tougher restrictions are
having an impact
overall the number of canadians testing
positive each day has begun to drop
ontario for example reported 670
new infections today and that is the
lowest daily case count
since late november here is the picture
across canada
adjusted for population the three
prairie provinces led by manitoba have
the most active cases per capita
though case counts have been dropping
there too in the last few weeks
underlying those numbers though are some
troubling indicators
hospitalizations remain much higher than
during the first wave and
more than 100 canadians are still dying
of covid19 every day
165 deaths were reported
just yesterday add to that the highly
contagious new variants and canada
is at a precarious point no one knows
yet how widely those variants are
spreading
if they take hold like they have in
other countries case numbers could
explode
and canada's already sluggish vaccine
rollout is facing
another hurdle pfizer biontech wants
health canada
to stretch the number of doses in each
vial from five
to six the company says that change
would help minimize vaccine wastage
as abigail beeman reports it's not that
simple
this is a standard syringe when the you
depress it all the way down
there's a lot of these there's just a
little bit of space left
you were never meant to inject that last
little bit into the person's arm it's
just a bit of dead space
and this is what's called a low dead
space syringe
you really do draw up exactly the volume
that you need
and you inject all of it into the
person's arm your measurements are a lot
more precise
pfizer wants health canada to approve a
change to its vaccine labels to show
each vial has six doses instead of five
and tells global news while a low dead
space syringe will work for
six with a standard syringe there may
only be
enough room for five doses the u.s food
and drug administration and europe
approved a similar request
in total canada has bought more than 145
million syringes
thirty seven and a half million of those
are low dead space ones
but by deadline the procurement
department wouldn't answer how many have
arrived
they're called a niche market right this
is a type of syringe that we do
sometimes use but it's not commonplace
this is not a syringe that we would have
expected to be planning for using
that this really was a bonus syringes
are no syringes
we're short on vaccine and even if we're
able to squeeze out one more dose per
vial
we still need vials and so i think that
that always remains front and center is
we need to do whatever we can to procure
more supply
on the question of whether canada will
end up paying the same amount of money
for less product
the government didn't comment by
deadline while pfizer tells global news
the agreement is based on doses
and not vials and they will fulfill the
commitment in line with health canada
approved labeling
abigail beeman global news ottawa
vaccine shortages mean canada's rollout
isn't happening as originally planned
indigenous services minister mark miller
said today the government is still
committed to immunizing
75 percent of people in the territories
before april
and he's urging provinces and
territories to keep indigenous people
as a top priority for vaccines we know
that indigenous populations
we have the numbers we have the
casualties to prove it are three and a
half times the five times more
vulnerable to covet
so when we talk about timing and vaccine
deployment every day counts
prime minister justin trudeau is again
reassuring canadians about
vaccine deliveries
during question period today trudeau
said he's spoken with the president of
the european commission about threats to
control
exports of vaccines produced in europe
trudeau says she assured him measures to
track
vaccine exports will not affect pfizer
biantec and moderna deliveries to canada
the eu wants pharmaceutical companies
producing covid19 vaccines to register
any exports of doses from europe
a canada post worker in ontario who
contracted covid19 has
died the man has not been identified and
his exact cause of death hasn't been
confirmed
he was a night shift worker at a canada
post plant in mississauga the union
representing postal workers told global
news
night shift employees were not required
to be tested for covet 19 but this man
got tested
anyway he had not worked at the site
since january 18th
224 cases of covid19 have been confirmed
at the same facility
since the start of this year and more
than 4 500 people work at the plant
at least 350 employees and contractors
have been told
to self-isolate for two weeks there is
more turbulence tonight in the canadian
airline industry air transat has
announced
it is suspending all flights from
toronto and some from montreal until
april 30th
because of falling demand the airline
says new federal measures requiring
travels
travelers to test negative for covid19
before flying to canada
have had a major impact on bookings
in the uk more than 100 000 people have
now died of covid and there's intense
pressure on prime minister boris johnson
to do more to protect lives
he announced today tighter restrictions
travelers including british citizens
who returned from countries where new
variants pose a risk
must quarantine in a hotel at their own
expense for 10 days
and everyone booking a trip out of the
country will be interrogated about their
reasons
i want to make clear that under the
stay-at-home regulations it
is illegal to leave home
to travel abroad for leisure purposes
and we will enforce this at ports
at airports by asking people why they
are leaving and
instructing them to return home if they
do not have
a valid reason to travel
the uk government has already banned
travel from 22 countries where its
known variants are spreading including
south africa portugal and brazil
also today the prime minister said
schools won't reopen in england until
march
8th at the earliest in the u.s president
joe biden's administration gave a frank
update today on the projected course of
the pandemic there
as many as as many as 90 000 more
americans are expected to die of covid19
in the next four weeks that is a
startling number
there are indications new case numbers
aren't rising as fast as they were but
that could change quickly as new
variants spread and as jackson proskow
reports vaccines aren't rolling out fast
enough
the first pandemic briefing from the
biden administration
right now on a level with the public
delivered a sharp dose of reality
it will be months before everyone who
wants a vaccine
will be able to get one the u.s faces
problems with vaccine supply and
distribution
and a shortage of medical professionals
to put needles into arms
the new administration has secured
hundreds of millions of additional doses
experts say the plans are not ambitious
enough to vaccinate 250 million adult
americans by summer
the current vaccination rate would have
to triple that's 100
million immunizations a month 3 million
a day so that's
the kinds of numbers i think we have to
get to
to get ahead of these new variants those
new virus variants have the white house
alarmed we have to be concerned
looking forward at what the further
evolution of this
might be the more contagious uk variant
is now in 26 states
and could be the dominant strain across
the u.s by march
as transmission really starts to go up
what you're going to see is more and
more americans are getting infected
and therefore more will die and the
longer you let this go on the more
likely it is you're going to get
variance that might even resist the
vaccine
case counts are starting to fall from a
peak of near 250 thousand cases per day
to around one hundred and sixty thousand
per day though i am encouraged by these
trends
our case rates remain extraordinarily
high
daily deaths have never been higher
eighty thousand lives lost so far in the
month of january
and that many more expected in the
coming weeks four hundred
seventy nine thousand to five hundred
fourteen
thousand covet nineteen deaths will be
reported
and by february twentieth experts warn
the only way to change course is a
dramatic change in attitudes
more masks and fewer interactions
measures to slow the spread
and save lives between now and
widespread vaccination
jackson prosco global news washington
president biden is moving ahead on
another top priority for his
administration
addressing climate change biden says the
u.s has already waited too long and that
america must lead the global response
he is making climate change both a
national security and a foreign policy
priority
and as eric sorenson reports that puts
the us into closer alignment
with canada no single heat wave or flood
and not one wildfire or calving glacier
proves climate change
but the accumulation of evidence is so
overwhelming that the political will to
act worldwide may have just reached a
turning point
it is an existential threat a new u.s
president
willing to put the might of the world's
biggest economy and the second biggest
polluter
behind sweeping changes an executive
order from joe biden will freeze new oil
and gas leases on federal lands and
offshore
a plan to eliminate fossil fuel
subsidies and to invest in green
innovation
and jobs including a doubling of
offshore wind production
and making climate a core component of
national security foreign policy
and across government departments we
can't wait any longer
and we see it with our own eyes we feel
it we know it in our bones
and it's time to act in optics alone
it's a 180 degree pivot from the
previous administration
what many believe were four years lost
to global warming
at a summit this week on climate
adaptation world leaders welcomed the
return of american leadership
i'd like to take this opportunity to
highly commend the
visionary leadership of president joe
biden of the united states
the multilateralism which has been in
disarray
during last four years is now back no
country will be more affected by the
change in washington than canada
alberta is licking its wounds after
biden shut down the keystone pipeline
but lining up climate policies
represents a glorious opportunity for a
liberal government
that believes in them president biden
has
a lot of similar priorities to this
government
cooperation could come in transportation
reducing carbon and methane emissions
clean energy exports and on the paris
agreement and new
climate targets and it offers an
opportunity for canada to
align with these efforts from the united
states these announcements also
represent an opportunity for canada to
scale up
its climate action a new un survey says
almost two-thirds of people worldwide
especially young people want action on
what they consider
a global emergency and it's the oldest
president in u.s history
who plans to take that action we know
what to do
we've just got to do it eric sorenson
global news
death threats against election
candidates coming up the collection of
weapons
found on a man in newfoundland and
labrador
there is more detail tonight about a
threat to politicians on the campaign
trail in newfoundland and labrador
rcmp allege a man intended to kill or
seriously injure the premier
and other local candidates as ross lord
explains the suspect led police
on a high-speed chase which ended with a
disturbing discovery
for newfoundland and labrador premier
andrew fury being targeted by a man with
a truck full of knives
is an alarming threat we've seen some
negativity
throughout this campaign and some
different
perhaps more online issues than we ever
thought we would in the past and
i had to see an event like this an
incident like this was was very
troubling to me and my family
we learned from the police that we that
i was the likely target
rcmp say fury was not the only
politician in danger
the rcmp had serious concerns for public
safety
including the safety of the sitting mha
for the area and political candidates
our cmp say the accused left the
community of bond bay in a truck
saying he was going to deer lake 67
kilometers away
to stop the election police say they
found the truck near the community of
cormac
but the driver refused to stop
continuing toward deer lake at a
dangerous rate of speed
they say the truck stopped at a deer
lake business that contained the office
of a pc candidate
police arrested the man seizing 36
hunting and tactical knives inside the
truck
police say after they stopped him the
suspect threatened to execute local
politicians
66 year old george brake has been
charged with following criminal offenses
possession of a weapon dangerous to
public peace
uttering threats to cause death
dangerous driving
and flight from police fury is a
candidate in deer lake
at the time of tuesday's events he was
in labrador it hits
close to home uh it makes you
question you know if you're doing the
right thing
especially in a province where the fear
factor is not normally a consideration
for political candidates that's not the
general status quo for
our people in our ways of behaving rcmp
say break
is in custody he'll be in court for a
bail hearing thursday
ross lord global news
in france the court of appeal has ruled
a canadian wanted in connection with a
1980 bombing outside a paris synagogue
must stand trial
three years ago lower court judges freed
hassan diab over a lack of evidence
the 67 year old's lawyer says he will
challenge
today's ruling it flies in the face
of the existing evidence you'll recall
that this is a case in canada that
was based on a sheer opinion a
handwriting opinion
that the world's leading experts all
unanimously agreed was completely
unreliable
our cmp officers arrested diab in 2008
at the request of france
following a lengthy court battle he was
extradited and spent three years in
prison there
in 2018 french judges dismissed the case
and ordered diab's release he returned
home to ottawa
dieb has denied involvement in the
attack that killed four people and
injured
more than 40 others cloris leachman an
actor who is fearless and funny
has passed away do you know how to
remove chocolate stains
yes i do oh good
leachman started her career on stage and
broke into film and television in 1947
and she kept working for decades you may
know her best from tv roles in
the mary tyler moore show and the facts
of life or
on the big screen in films like young
frankenstein
and the last picture show for which she
won an oscar
no other actress has been nominated for
more emmys and she tied for the most
wins
leachman passed away from natural causes
last night at her home in california
she was 94.
pandemic probe still ahead a new covet
test happening behind closed doors
in china
indonesia's most active volcano mount
merapi is erupting again
at least 150 people had to leave their
homes and there have been
no reports of injuries or deaths the
volcano has erupted repeatedly in recent
weeks
the area has been under the country's
second highest alert level since
november hong kong is using a drastic
new tactic to control covet 19
the government has begun ambush style
lockdowns closing off entire
neighborhoods with no warning
everyone within the area gets tested for
covet 19. hong kong has been struggling
to contain a fourth wave of the virus
nearly 40 percent of all infections
there have been recorded
in the last two months and china is
using a new kind of covid test one that
sounds a little uncomfortable
scientists say data has shown traces of
the coronavirus last
longer in the digestive tract than in
the nose or throat so
china is using anal swabs to test for
covid19 yes anal
swabs only certain high risk groups are
being tested this way as you can imagine
the invasive technique is not
sitting well with everyone china has
taken other extreme measures to stop the
spread of covid19 locking down
entire cities and provinces to contain
outbreaks
tighter restrictions are being reimposed
now ahead of lunar new year
celebrations are the kids
all right next the pandemic's impact on
teen mental health
the work never stops on the
international space station astronauts
michael hopkins and victor glover who
arrived there in november
ventured outside to finish installing a
european space agency platform
it will allow astronauts to conduct
science and technology demonstrations
outside the space station
they worked for almost seven hours and
at one point joked they wished they
could pop into the airlock for some
snacks
and bacon well floating in space would
be a welcome
escape from what we're all dealing with
here on earth the pandemic has now
lasted long enough for research to be
done
on what only illnesses deaths and
restrictions are doing to our mental
health
tonight heather urix west looks at the
impact on teenagers
normally kyra cato is in the gym
training in gymnastics more than 30
hours a week
but since november her gym has been
closed it has been pretty frustrating
but um i try to keep a positive
outtake outlook on everything but it
gets hard
i opened up the other night
asking questions about how they were
feeling and i had a lot of
responses that were actually like quite
heart-wrenching
coach janna ball says many of her
athletes are struggling right now with
feelings of anxiety and
depression unsure of how long they'll
have to wait
before things start to feel normal again
we're
seeing changes over the months that
we've done our study we're seeing
and most of it is going in the wrong
direction
a calgary research project launched at
the beginning of the school year
surveyed more than 2
thousand high school students in calgary
and edmonton
in september it found 17 percent or 1 in
6 were experiencing critical levels of
poor mental health by december when
students were surveyed again
that number had risen to more than 20
percent or about
one in five across the country mental
health professionals are seeing demand
for their services rise
calls to the kids help phone more than
doubled in 2020
indicating that not only are more young
people struggling
but more people are reaching out for
help the most important thing is that
our young people are talking about what
they're experiencing and
they're going through the process of
trying to figure out some solutions for
themselves
that can help them get through this
pandemic fifteen-year-old jane sherwood
says she's using
art and music to get through these
difficult times and talking to her
parents more
as well i've become a lot more closer
with my family through this and so
i think that we've kind of like
established an uh like a new kind of
like openness with that kind of thing
which i think has helped a lot learning
how to be resilient
during an incredibly challenging time
heather urex west global news
calgary and that is global national for
this wednesday i'm donna friesen
today is international holocaust
remembrance day it's been 76 years since
the liberation of auschwitz the most
notorious of nazi death camps
more than 1.1 million people the
majority of them jewish died in that
camp
just a fraction of the more than 6
million jews killed in the holocaust
israel marked the day with a virtual
ceremony
in the uk the london eye was among the
sites bathed in purple light
and in warsaw poland an 88 year old
holocaust survivor laid a wreath
in the former warsaw ghetto germany's
president said today
the greatest danger for all of us begins
with forgetting thanks for watching hope
to see you here again tomorrow
take care of yourselves